what are we gonna do about the crime
epidemic in los angeles and by the crime
epidemic i really mean seth rogen and
youtube's own casey neistat going at it
on twitter yeah you've seen this yes
okay
they have a nice little twitter back and
forth we can pop a picture up i'm gonna
pull it up and show that it actually is
kind of friendly it's not
antagonistic really in any way i think
that
if you're someone who's from los angeles
we have someone from los angeles here uh
both of them are clear living in los
angeles uh casey used to live in new
york obviously that's when he was uh you
know doing all these amazing vlogs and
really like making vlogging a
uh lifestyle for people like all these
people who are vlogging right now are
doing it because of casey casey started
vlogging he did the vlog every single
day i mean it's unbelievable what he did
um so if you hate vlogs you blame casey
neistat if you love them then you should
thank him but he revolutionized a form
of storytelling on youtube yeah
and he was exceptional uh so he
basically his like kid's car got broken
into in l.a he tweets out i'm hoping we
can get i think his car got broken into
and he had stuff for his daughter's
birthday i think is what he was saying
ah that's what i think i've got a
mistake and mark's blowing it up right
now so basically so our cars got robbed
this morning because los angeles is a
crime riddled third world [ __ ] of a
city but tremendous appreciation and
gratitude to the hard-working officers
of the lapd west la who not only
arrested the [ __ ] but they got
all of our stolen goods back okay
um now that is what casey said
now uh
what's his face seth rogen responds he
goes dude i've lived here here for 20
years you're nuts haha it's lovely here
don't leave anything valuable in it
being the car it's called living in a
big city and then casey goes i can be
mad though right i feel so violated and
seth goes you can be mad but i guess i
don't personally view my car as an
extension of my of myself and i've never
really felt violated any of the 15 or so
times my car was broken into once a guy
accidentally left a cool knife in my car
so it keeps happening you might get a
little treat and casey goes i didn't get
any treats he just took the decorations
from my daughter's seventh birthday and
left bloody handprints serious question
how did your car get broken into 15
times and he goes i lived in
west hollywood for 20 years and parked
on the street also sexier [ __ ] was
stolen but la's not some [ __ ] as far
as big cities go it has a lot going for
it okay
couple things going on right now uh i
think right wing
folks need a new chrissy teigen and uh
unfortunately for seth he tweets enough
with the opinions uh that he has where
he's about to be that and i don't know
if seth realizes it but they're making
him that right he seems to be tweeting
on any big cultural moments he seems to
be sharing an opinion and having it he
might be high making [ __ ] places to
roll your weed up and sell them on the
internet thinking he don't give a [ __ ]
you know making movies doing this kind
of stuff but what's gonna happen is
right name right-wing people need a
right-wing twitter need a hollywood
celeb to hate and he shares all the
opinions right of the people they like
to hit right and he engages with and he
engages every day he goes back and forth
yeah and he's getting tons of positive
feedback too so i'm sure all of like his
friends that are in hollywood are like
yeah tell them our city's not that bad
etcetera that's what i did like to make
the argument for him when i was on rogan
and roger was like new york as whack i
was like no it's not [ __ ] great i
would defend my city too yeah people are
saying new york is falling apart and i
was like bro this is new york like this
is kind of what it looks like
now
i also understand casey which
he sees frustration in getting his car
broken into he also probably sees la the
landscape of la looking a little bit
differently post pandemic and even
during the pandemic we see all these
videos popping out of people getting
robbed while they're eating yeah you
know very casual robberies like yeah if
this is the way to get the rid of the uh
you know eating in the street thing yeah
then that's the perfect way to do it you
know like if that's how the city wanted
to shut down outdoor dining like you
know new york they gave
the ability to have all the people in
the street like the way to do it is just
have a few videos of people just getting
robbed for their watches while they're
eating a [ __ ] smoothie or something
like that i'm eating this sorry there's
a video right here we'll play
um
now this is a hundred percent a setup
like
100 this is set up but whatever we'll
talk about that later so he just pulls
up with the gun with the extendo clip i
think and uh yeah he got the extenno
clip and they just takes both their
watches they go back to eating and then
they're out of there and these people at
this table don't even know nobody has a
[ __ ] it's inside oh yeah they went
inside wow that's that's wild
anyway
point being is that i think seth is
about to become this next version right
so he should be very careful about that
because you know what young conservative
kids they like his movies too they like
that humor yeah right so i don't think
that he wants to become this like very
polarizing political figure when
he probably doesn't even care i don't
know what he really cares about but i'm
sure he cares more about like making
movies than he does like making
arguments about whether la has enough
crime or doesn't yeah yeah also this
this argument of like um
it's just life in a big city it's like
when does that stop it's like when
people are just punching asians in the
head is that there's life in the big
city yeah what are you talking about
donation is like and when they're
beating up jews and [ __ ] bro
yeah it's life in a big city people do
the exact opposite when they talk about
america's problems they'll be like
america there's like racism here and
blah blah
i don't think she'll be the response and
she'd be like oh yeah it's a great place
but we should try to improve it we can
approve getting your [ __ ] stolen yeah
but i also understand people being
defensive over city that they live in
that is being kind of used in a culture
war to showcase that like defunding the
police is bad and the democrat-run
cities are shitty yeah right and i
guarantee you i don't guarantee but my
suspicion is if casey neistat did not
compliment the police seth rogen doesn't
respond
i don't know
just trashing the city i think it's a
combination of calling the city a
[ __ ] and complimenting the police
because those tap into two things i
think it's the city of [ __ ] and i
also think he the one tweet that i
thought was telling when he was like i
guess i just don't view a car as an
extension of myself where a lot of
people you get your car broken into they
feel violated to him it's like
you leave a [ __ ] jacket somewhere and
someone steals it or like you leave an
umbrella somewhere and someone steals it
it's like all right it's just a thing
you took it that's fine why you get why
acting so [ __ ] crazy about it yeah
you don't insult my city because of
[ __ ] car breaking who cares yeah you
still got the car i think that's how
he's saying
people who [ __ ] love cars and like
that's my baby every one of them be like
yo that's [ __ ] up also having kids i
think plays the world too yeah but you
get your shoes broken into and they
steal something that belongs to your
kids that affects your kids all of a
sudden you're not dealing with your car
you're dealing with an extension of like
your family and like except
for your kids say again you let someone
to your kids yeah exactly
it psychologically [ __ ] you up whereas
if you don't have kids it's like like i
don't have kids someone broke into my
car be like whatever yeah and casey also
is a i think a fairly left dude like he
was
very vocally against trump he said he
voted for biden in 2020 like this is a
guy that's not like some
republican spokesperson thanking the
cops
but they're private not private their
public conversation is being used in
this culture yes yes absolutely and i
think that
unfortunately for both of them like i
don't know casey never seemed like the
most political figure but i'm not a big
casey fan so i don't know i don't really
know i know he had one vlog that he said
like he said it the wrong way but he was
there like if you are voting for trump
you are co-signing racism misogyny blah
blah blah right he said some [ __ ] like
that he was pretty so they probably
agree on political [ __ ] yeah so i think
casey is trying to be objective going
like yo i've lived here the [ __ ] the
city looks worse than it did yeah we
should probably do something to change
it and here's a per i mean dove you're
you're from l.a you've experienced l.a
absolutely different in the last few
years absolutely notably and it's on
both sides so before they're like okay
the homeless population that's growing
the police aren't really policing that
the pandemic kind of pushed that forward
but
the
voting in of this district attorney
which for folks that want to know what
really
changes your city makeup he was also the
d.a of san francisco george piece of
[ __ ] garbage gascon go [ __ ] your own
pace she came to
won't
l.a
people in the same way and i mean like
i'm all for you know drug crimes things
like that or you know misdemeanors in
that sense but when it comes to crimes
and knowing that you can get away with
[ __ ] it's open season so in other words
like violent crimes not getting
prosecuted the same is what you're
saying
we don't know i don't know if it is that
what's yours no violence he's against
that he wants a different type of reform
he's really dumb so the prosecution of a
specific crime
if you're believing what dove is saying
would uh either
promote or inhibit you doing that crime
if you're a criminal in other words
right now you see a lot of these videos
of people running into a cvs so they run
into a walgreens and they take a bunch
of things i think that's basically
because like all crime under 900 dollars
well theft is uh you get a citation it's
not looked at as a felony yeah right and
and he's been an advocate against cash
bail so people that commit something i
mean they're just out right away instead
of like holding them and i mean a lot of
these offenders you're hearing stories
like committing uh five crimes in a week
yeah you just know they're gonna be out
so yeah yeah so i guess
yeah so i guess that's frustrating and
then i listen i'm not gonna be somebody
who sits here and goes yeah i understand
how a district attorney affects the city
right no [ __ ] clue yeah but i do
understand how
um
the penalty for an illegal for an
illegal activity could
change my willingness to do it right
given i really needed something right
for example let's say i need 500 to make
rent right
and i could steal 500 worth of [ __ ] from
walgreens that i could resell or i could
rob someone on the street
robin's on the street that's different
yeah i might go to jail for that yeah
but if i know all i got to do is play a
citation for stealing this [ __ ] from
walgreens yeah
and they're not going to go against you
you try to rob someone they might fight
you they could kill you they could have
a knife yeah going to cvs you could just
walk out and it's easy to not feel bad
for cbs it's easy to be like i'm robbing
a [ __ ] billion dollar corporation not
some guy going to his job who cares yeah
i'm listening i'm like yeah
that's why those videos i think we were
talking about this yesterday a little
bit but that's why those videos are
people getting like robbed uh while
they're eating yeah that's why those
videos are so profound like it's because
when you see someone rob a louis vuitton
short there's part of you it's also like
man [ __ ] louis vuitton yeah i don't see
myself on louis vuitton yeah like no
you're too expensive for me i can't
afford you [ __ ] you yeah it's on some
robin hood [ __ ] it's like finally steal
from the rich i wish i had the balls to
steal some louis vuitton boom it's like
a bank robber movie like i love living
through that guy you eat a burger and
fries a [ __ ] comes up to you
while you're on a date with your girl
takes your watch you're like oh [ __ ]
that shit's emasculating bro yeah i like
watches i like burgers and fries i got a
girl yep that might happen so ann takes
your girl's watch too
yeah it's like you know i paid for that
come on
twice watch i'm thinking i saw this i
was like bro i can't go eating on that
with with this watch in l.a i can put a
[ __ ] calculator if someone wants my
apple watch what if they want you know
yeah yeah it could happen yeah yeah at
any time they could just walk into apple
it's less than 900
just gonna have to take that [ __ ] right
off the [ __ ]
sprint out the store what are they gonna
do yeah it's tricky i i don't totally
understand if you're someone from la you
feel more affected by this why you'd be
upset and why you would rally to the
people defending you right the people
that are out there going yo we need to
do something about the crime you know we
need to do something about the homeless
you know we need to do something and
then you see a guy like seth rogen who
probably lives i would assume in an area
where he doesn't have to deal with as
much of this stuff
and he's just going life is good yeah i
don't blame his perspective either
because like he's insulated from it yeah
like but you can't blame him for not
knowing
yeah blame you like if you know for a
fact i think this is why there's so much
resentment for the uh
uh the hollywood elites if you will buy
like the right wing twitter brigade is
because they're like you benefit from
all the [ __ ] we fight for
like we don't want to pay a lot in taxes
you don't
yeah you got these tax attorneys they're
finding ways where you get to skip out
on [ __ ] taxes and then you're going
to [ __ ] on us for saying we want lower
taxes yeah right you're talking about
the i mean this is almost like a hacking
example you talk about the build the
wall [ __ ] and it's just like
you have your little walls you know you
have your little walls that block off
your [ __ ] gated communities those
walls work for you but you're gonna [ __ ]
on us and call us races for more to
build a wall yeah i think there's
there's another one about um
well i forget exactly what it was but
the idea is like all the things that we
get criticized we the right-wing
[ __ ] they're going all the
things we get criticized for you
actually profit from
and you enable in your own lives so who
the [ __ ] are y'all to criticize us and i
guess they would say conversely the
things you advocate for you don't got to
deal with
so like if you're advocating for like oh
like open border like no one's illegal
it's like yeah you live in a place where
it's all white people want to get home
oh it was the it was the security thing
it was like yeah we should defund the
police and it's like well you have
privacy
no one's touching you no matter what
yeah so the people that actually might
need the police now they're getting
[ __ ] yeah you will never get [ __ ]
you'll never get touched so you can be
this advocate for all these things that
don't affect you in any way right so
shut your [ __ ] mouth but i get their
perspective because like they're living
their life through their lens and they
put themselves in this position where
they worked hard and got all this money
and they're able to afford all these
luxuries that like maybe work hard
actors maybe seth rollins seth rogen
i give seth rogen credit if you write if
you direct if you just act you don't
work hard yeah yeah yeah that's why you
think tatum not working [ __ ]
once he stopped dancing that
[ __ ] stopped working when he was
dancing in those movies that's work yeah
choreography magic mikey he wasn't
working w-e-r-k
[ __ ] back on the polio yeah
i don't want to hear about this [ __ ]
yeah but if you put yourself in a
position where you're insulated from
life it's like yeah i get why you have
that perspective like you become out of
touch because you put yourself out of
touch because being in touch is hard but
does being out of touch absolve you from
criticism for your perspective not
necessarily like i empathize with and i
get it because like i'm probably out of
touch with the [ __ ] on a global level
yeah
so i'm like yeah i get it like i'm not
really actively working to understand
the i get it but he can still be
criticized and maybe that criticism will
have him open his eyes and go oh [ __ ]
maybe there's something going on right
here interesting it's easy it's easy
when you're chilling on your [ __ ]
massive i don't know where he lives or
how he lives but it's easy if you're
chilling in the hills on your estate and
you have a pool and you're looking over
the city and from above the city look
all right yeah you know l.a looks fine
from above yeah you know it looks
beautiful it looks like there's no crime
going on at least the robberies are
quiet now you know what i mean like
there's so yeah i also think he caught
some left-wing criticism for this too
because he was detached from societies
he's judging the struggles of everyday
people that's a christie and that's yeah
that's the i think this is the perfect
twitter story because it lets everybody
be outraged yeah because if you're left
or right you can be outrageous seth
rogen you're so out of touch and then
you if you're left you can be outraged
with casey neistat how can you call it a
third world [ __ ] that's too strong
some like feminist spokesperson came out
and was like the wording was too mean
it's like bruh he just got his card
yeah you got your card broken into it
would still be pc your daughter's
seventh birthday is ruined but you need
to make sure you're not politic you're
not insensitive toward an inanimate
object
i had the uh uh who was who i got to
keep the name private but uh
they said their reaction was uh you
can't call it third world because
the cops wouldn't come
what do you mean third world you got
your [ __ ] back yeah yeah i'm saying come
and help you and you definitely ain't
getting your [ __ ] second at least
yeah
yeah yeah definitely but yeah this is
the most first world [ __ ] that the cops
would actually arrest the people that
stole your [ __ ] out of your car and you
would get everything back that only
happens exclusively in the nicest parts
of the first world yeah or if you're
rich in the third world so casey neistat
might have got it anywhere
but that's it everybody else uh you hey
i was gonna arrest a guy but he bribed
me so what's going on you don't even get
your kids back
i don't know if you getting your [ __ ]
back you know what i mean like that's a
that's a maybe in the third world yeah
you get your kids stolen in mexico you
better have the money yeah i'm not
familiar with latin american third world
talking asian american third world oh
yeah yeah yeah that's they're gonna know
who took your [ __ ] oh if you're rich
you're taking care you're fine we'll
take care of you you're rich if you're
politically connected you're good like
your life is good you're protected even
if you get robbed they're going to get
your stuff back i think so you probably
got we i think i stayed in a place with
like armed guards outside would people
be less likely to rob from a rich person
because they go oh there's gonna be hell
to pay yeah for this i could just rob
from like a slightly richer person than
me that doesn't have [ __ ] anymore yeah
absolutely yeah absolutely and then cops
don't give a [ __ ] but yeah i think the
conservative reaction is to look at
someone like seth rogen be like yo this
guy's a piece of [ __ ] like he hates the
regular people he hates conservatives
like blah blah blah i think that's
something
if you're in his spot you probably think
the same thing i don't think he's an
evil person i literally i think he's out
of touch yeah i i i think there's a
little bit out of touch and i think
there's also like an uber defensiveness
like you ever have your girl criticize
something that is true about your mom
and you're like yo yo yo why are you
saying that yeah i agree but why are you
saying it yeah like so like it could be
something that is facts like my mom's
brussels sprouts are trash yeah and her
carrots were awful but just hearing my
girl be like yeah like i tried to pick
up the carrot
right through it and i'm like yo
i ball my fists right now
keep talking about my mom's trash
so i think there's a little bit of that
like
that [ __ ] lived there for a
while put the time in sees everybody
[ __ ] on his city just like how i
felt with new york i was like nah i
don't even care if [ __ ] getting
robbed non-stop that's new york don't
get robbed stupid also if you went
through it and you made it you look at
that guy like shut the [ __ ] up with your
little complaining yeah like your
parents who made it through tougher [ __ ]
than you and wherever they're from when
you complain about saying shut the [ __ ]
up yeah how many times has happened to
me yeah yeah that's not an excuse you
did do that with new york but big time
people were like rick moranis just got
punched on the upper side yeah yo check
your back
come on rick
you know what i mean
[Laughter]
real talk that's i did do that man we
always
got knocked out in l.a you'd be like yo
what's wrong with this they're falling
apart what this is falling apart
now isn't seth rogen from vancouver or
some [ __ ] yeah yeah don't don't talk
about vancouver
[Music]
you out here
you